we spend a lot of our lives lying to
someone very close to home ourselves we
lie because so many of the things we
feel are humiliating challenging strange
and unflattering we don't just forget to
acknowledge our feelings one part of the
mind actively shields the other from
uncomfortable truths but the cost of our
denial is high because emotions that
have not been properly confronted leads
to a psychological impoverishment
brittleness rage and deceit it is deeply
uncomfortable to want something that one
can't have so a standard form of denial
is to reinvent how much one ever really
wanted the elusive element in the first
place we reevaluate what a thing means
to us it might be a job the holiday or a
person when it becomes clear it can
never be ours it takes exceptional
maturity to hold on to the idea that
something might be at once precious and
yet forever
and maddeningly out of reach perhaps you
were 14 and entering a new class when
you notice an extraordinary new student
taller than you with gray green eyes
thick open hair and an intelligent wry
smile they were one of the most charming
people you'd ever encountered and also
utterly beyond you you were pimply and
immature you couldn't do sports you
weren't great at languages of course you
might have tried to become their friend
you might have shared jokes and chitchat
but this kind of compromise would have
hurt too much so to reduce the pain
you became nasty you started to hate the
person you liked you sought to spoil
because you could not have you became
mean where you would at one level have
wanted to worship you called them a
stuck-up idiot and worse you organized a
group to torment them one time you stole
their scarf you escaped your feelings
through a denigration that heared not
hatred but at base a passionate secret
love
sometimes our meanness takes drier more
intellectual forms perhaps at the office
you recently sent random memo headed
recruitment policies for q4 sales team
in it you argued in sober prose with
numbered paragraphs that the company
shouldn't in the future seek to recruit
any more recent university graduates on
the grounds that they tended not to meet
the expectations of clients the need for
this kind of high-flown self-deception
began the day you first laid eyes on the
new recruit who seemed astonishingly
young enthusiastic endearing and
desirable the emotions you felt were a
piece of madness for a married
middle-aged person the target of your
desire was 23 with coltish energy and
innocent friendliness on the second week
they tried to ask you what you've done
on the weekend and mentioned that they
tried windsurfing for the first time you
responded by being rather Stern with
colleagues you judged their performance
in a critical way that seemed just about
fair at a committee meeting you damned
them with faint praise and at the
earliest opportunity you made sure that
contract was not renewed of course being
honest about our real feelings doesn't
mean we should always act on them
it's not a good idea to make every
feeling known to those it concerns the
choice we face isn't between denial and
inaction or honesty followed by a
brusque move on the people around us we
can accept many of our desires without
needing to think we should do anything
about them the best way to overcome
denial of some of our more impossible
desires for people is to accept who we
are what we want and then sometimes just
sit with our hands firmly tied
reflecting sadly on the deep strangeness
and unsatisfactoriness of the human
condition but that will be a lot better
than self-deception and meanness
you